hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
streamline your path from
immunodiagnostic development to
commercialization
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
anthony keoli director global oem and
licensing protein and cell analysis
thermo fisher scientific
anthony you may now begin your
presentation
good morning and thank you for joining
today's webinar my name is anthony kuli
i am a director of global
oem and licensing with in thermos
fisher's protein and cell analysis
segment
i started my career in r d developing
diagnostic you know assays
and i've been in the business for over
20 years partnering with
customers globally to optimize
a wide range of thermo fisher products
and capabilities as part of their
diagnostic and life science product
commercialization
so thermo fisher is uh comprised of many
different divisions
what i've shown this slide here
highlights the four segments within our
biosciences division
these include our cell biology molecular
biology
protein and cell analysis and sample
prep segments
each of these segments have
individual reagents instruments and
complete solutions for life sciences and
diagnostics
i will be focusing today on the use of
products and capabilities within our
protein and cell analysis and sample
prep segments
and how
our customers can accelerate their
immunodiagnostic product development and
commercialization
with the emergence of covet 19 our
customers
product development and
commercialization of diagnostic tests
and vaccines has required
the utmost urgency to provide various
components required
along with the ability to meet the
rapidly increasing scale required at the
at the best quality
uh when our customers partner with
thermofisher they have access to a
complete portfolio of products and
capabilities
that enable faster asset development
along with security supply
as an example how this
works for our partners i would like to
start by reviewing some of our stars
cove 2 sa reagents
thermo fisher is one of the leading
experts for development in manufacturing
immunoassays
on various platforms this slide shows
our stars code 2 eliza
we have used
our years of expertise to develop some
of the best serology assays
to be able to measure stars code to
specific antibodies in serum or plasma
various
research use applications can include
things such as epidemiology studies
qc validation for vaccine development
or basic understanding
of research of the virus
the combination
of the spike trimer
structure and the total antibody
detection provides an accurate reading
of showers cove to animate detection
thereby minimizing false positives or
negatives
assays can be run either qualitatively
as a positive negative or as a
quantitative
assay using a standard curve
so thermofisher products like this eliza
are available for internal research
you're solving
so if a customer would like to use
either this elisa or perhaps one of the
components within this eliza
in their products they need to work with
our global oem team to confirm that we
have the rights
to offer this product for their
customers intended use
so that's what i want to highlight today
is
how do you take an existing product from
thermo fisher and commercialize it in
your diagnostic development
one of the key components
of an eliza
are antibodies
thermo fisher offers a wide range of
over a hundred thousand antibodies
and these include things such as these
uh recombinant stars co2 antibodies
all antibodies that customers would
like to potentially use commercially
should first be reviewed by thermo
fisher to make sure that we're able to
convey
the commercial rights
for the customer's intended use
confirming commercial rights is just one
way that our global oem team supports
our customers
and i will discuss how we do that over
the next few slides
in addition to uh confirming commercial
rights our global oem team
offers our partners a variety of
benefits
these include the ability to customize
any of our products and services
access to our team of technical experts
and resources
to be able to
scale along with our partners
commercialization um
a long-term commitment
that provides our partners with security
supply and business terms
and regulatory support to deliver the
product
specifications that are required by our
partners as well as change notification
if something has to change
our antibodies are provided for internal
research use only
it is important to contact
your global oem representative to
perform antibody review to make sure
that
you are able to commercialize
your product for your intended use
demo fisher sources our antibodies
many different ways so we have our own
internal
in-house antibodies but we also
unlicense
antibodies from third parties or
are supplied from third parties
and depending on the antibody some uses
in our partners products may not be
permitted
to minimize risk for both us and our
partners
thermo fisher has created a team of
experts that
review all intended uses of the
antibodies
that we offer through our global oem
channel
um this is referred to as our antibody
review team um
it's also
internally called art
where we will obtain the necessary
approvals where possible and execute
supply and license agreements
to ensure
contractual compliance and thereby
protect both our partners and thermo
fisher
we offer this support to avoid potential
issues in the future where
uh an antibody is is commercially used
uh for an application that is not
approved there's uh
nothing worse than
for uh one of our partners to be
procuring one of our antibodies
and
to find out that they could not use it
for their commercial use at a later
point so we offer this
review to make sure that up front we are
giving the appropriate rights
to our customers where possible
thermo fisher customers have access
to the highest quality products
with a desired lot to lock consistency
having this comprehensive
offering of immunodiagnostic reagents
gives our customers
one-stop sourcing
which can be especially beneficial
when other suppliers do not have
reagents
this schematic here shows various
components that are found within an
immunoassay from the solid phase which
could be
for example a magnetic bead or a latex
particle
or or even a elisa plate
to the antibody that is conjugated to
this bead or plates
as well as various uh buffers and
detection reagents within the amino acid
thermal fissure has
the flexibility
to manufacture each of these reagents
as made to order
which helps maximize shelf life for our
partners
as well as the ability to customize and
scale with increasing demand
thereby uh minimizing the number of lots
that are required so this can be very
important um when you
our partners are looking to minimize
costs for example uh for doing qc but
also for
having more consistent results
for their own products
[Music]
[Music]
thermo fisher does offer a wide variety
of products for immunodiagnostics
developments
and on this slide from left to right
you can see the five main
categories
of reagents and products that we offer
starting with our capture surface
reagents
so this includes things such as
avidin or shipped avid and neutrality
as well as our latex particles that can
be fluorescent
and are magnetic beads
the next category is our primary and
secondary antibodies which could be then
labeled
with various things such as dyes or
enzymes
uh followed by our non-specific binding
category so this
represents things such as
detergents and blocking buffers
the next category being conjugation so
this is where you're cross-linking
various things or by attenuating various
things um in your immunoassay and lastly
uh our substrates and dyes
category which includes
some cutting edge products within the
chemin luminescence and fluorescent
spaces
so this is
substrates for
alkaline with alpha and phosphate
substrates and hrp substrates as well as
our dyes such as alexa
[Music]
so in terms of these categories we make
sure over our many years of supporting
our partners and you know diagnostics
that's
these products deliver the quality
and performance that our our customers
require um and
our partners expect to be able to lean
on us um to provide the reproducibility
and quality of of these products
um and as you look at this this slide
here you can see that this is
represented in different ways so
in terms of our capture surface reasons
for example you know we
really pride ourselves on being able to
deliver
the same performance from lots a lot
with the same quality um so that our
customers are not worried about that
um
you know and for any of our products we
want to be able to
um provide that reproducibility that is
needed immunodiagnostics once
a product is developed by one of our
partners they need to understand what
kind of tolerances that they have and
they rely on us to supply
the same material over and over again
and
if if something happens to be able to
identify the problem quickly and resolve
it
this is where open communication and
partnering can be very important
and provide consistent products to our
customers
[Music]
so how to benefit uh from being our
partner we um assist our partners by uh
providing access to a team of experts
um that can help overcome issues when
they arise um
for any of our immunodiagnostic products
the products can be customized
to optimize performance
as
as a partner is developing their product
you know customization
is can be very valuable because that
would help optimize performance
and performance can not just mean the
performance of the assay but
things such as stability
can be very important to our partners
so having the ability to customize and
to scale can be
you know a really
helpful
uh
for our partners in terms of delivering
the the highest quality and a
comprehensive
partnership between um us and and them
and this includes things such as you
know the ability to confirm commercial
rights but also you know change
notification as well
there's nothing
um more concerning to not have any
visibility to things that happen
unbeknownst to
our partners so
when a
raw material supply is changed we have
the ability to confirm
with our partners
that that that has happened and help
validate if necessary
so um with that i would like to uh
highlight some of our manufacturing
capabilities
uh within thermo fisher we have a
team of
synthetic
organic chemists both from an r d and a
manufacturing perspective
that supports
the production
of a variety of different products and
these include things such as
cross linkers
biotinylation reagents
substrates
and by having this team we are able to
go from milligram to kilogram scale
of these products
as well as the ability to customize
things such as
[Music]
various
quality control
assays
to meet the
the customer's needs so
this is a valuable resource for our
partners to have access to these this
team of synthetic organic chemists
similarly we have a team of folks that
specialize in the
formulation of buffers and reagents and
chromatographic supports
so what this means is
for a product that's a formulation um we
can make uh watt sizes up to 5 000
liters in batch size
uh which
uh when when scaling is very important
the ability to not just make
uh the one liter batch but also to make
up to 5000 liter batches this goes
across
many different products such as our
blocking buffers our detergents
um
our enzyme substrates
so having the ability to formulate into
to
make this this scale you know from
milliliters to kilometers can be very
important
for our diagnostic partners
in terms of other capabilities we have
in the areas of proteins antibodies and
labeling
we offer various
types of uh protein purification
bioconjugation
[Music]
use of avidines and and plate coating
we have
abilities to lyophilization um so all of
these
um protein and antibody modifications uh
are available these capabilities are
available to our partners as they're
developing their immunoassay so these
these components can be
very valuable to to be able to support
our partners with their
internal
development needs
[Music]
we also have the abilities to
package and finish products to our
customers requirements so
just because
we offer a particular product in a in a
specific bottle or packaging doesn't
mean that that's the optimal
packaging for our partners
so we have the ability to bottle
all of our products in various ways
it could be into an ambula or different
size bottle
we can do
powder pouching dry box filling
we have automated systems for filling
and capping
and we have the ability to kit
a combination of our products if need be
so having this these packaging options
can help secure and deliver our quality
for our partners
and
ability to take some of
our capabilities and and take them from
our partners and do them internal for
them so that they they receive the
material
faster for their product development
[Music]
thermofisher has a
team of quality control specialists that
can perform a wide variety of tests
to enable um
more consistent performance from lots to
lot
by partnering with our team
we can customize these quality control
tests
um in comparison to
products that are off the shelf so we
have our products that are on the web
that are for uh sold for internal
research use only and they have specific
quality control tests
to
make sure that they perform as as
intended
but sometimes for diagnostics
that's not enough the the
the range
of the quality control test should
potentially be more of them
depending on the application and and it
could be things such as
smaller ranges of ph
or um other functional type of assays to
help validate that
the product that the thermofisher
provides our partners
is to the quality uh that they're
expecting um so
being able to customize quality control
to
any of our products is a very valuable
uh resource
to
help
with the
commercialization process for our
partners
hand in hand with quality is our
regulatory support so
our
oem partners require
things such as lots a lot consistency of
our components
and having the regulatory support
for this
is very valuable so
things such as change notification can
be important if something
[Music]
was to go wrong the ability to audit our
sites and work together to find
what a potential issue might be and
offer solutions
is a valuable
asset for our partners to be able to
partner with us and insight audits are
are definitely
an option for our partners to be able to
understand what our processes are and
what what how we could potentially
improve things going forward
[Music]
i i believe it's important to understand
um
the various centers of excellence that
we have within thermo fisher
um
because it helps to
these products understand
technologies and capabilities are coming
from
and what what they are at our various
sites
so on this side we have listed
many manufacturing sites within our
protein and cell analysis business
thermo fisher is a combination of many
different companies and technologies
uh going from left to right here on this
side uh i would like to provide you a
little bit of background
on each site
so
on the top left our eugene oregon site
was or is our molecular probes business
that many may be familiar with
the site specializes in things such as
fluorescent dyes
including our alexa floor in quantum
dots
as well as latex particles and some
conjugation technologies
such as cyclic
and
instrumentation as well so for example
our attune flow cytometer is based there
our carlsbad california sites
is a combination of our
in vitrogen and ebioscience businesses
as it relates to
protein and cell analysis
this site specializes in flow antibodies
and reagents
our rockford illinois sites is
our pierce business
and they specialize in a wide range of
proteins ranging from cross-linkers to
detergents blocking buffers antibodies
and substrates
next
is the bedford massachusetts site which
was was our tropics business and they
specialize
in
chemicals and substrates that are used
in immunodiagnostics
next is our vienna austria site
which was our bender business
and
they focus on manufacturing of our
elizas
our
vilnius lithuania sites
performs protein production and is a
also a cgmp site for those
partners that require a higher level of
quality
all of these sites are iso 9001 but
the building a site is
again it's cgmp
and last on the list is our bangalore
site and we do our antibody development
in in bangalore
developing an immunoassay is a
partnership from the initial
developments through the launch thermo
fisher's
global oem and licensing team
supports
our partners development and
commercialization of immunodiagnostic
assays
letting them select a wide array of
products and technologies
our our team of uh
subject matter experts uh use many their
many years of experience to help
guide and customize
uh reagent selections and confirm
that the commercial rights and necessary
licenses are in place
for the components that are being
sourced
so working together with the gold team
can help
to
ensure consistent performance and
security supply for
important reagents
post launch we work with our partners to
maintain
uh performance through features uh such
as uh lots like consistency and change
notification and and
valuable um
mentorship in in valuing our customers
as well so working together as a team
it's all about communication
ability to deliver products to our
customers when they need it
with the quality that they need
with that i'd like to thank you for
staying on this webinar and now we can
answer any questions you may have
thank you anthony for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
where can i find more information on
these thermo fisher products and
capabilities
yeah so uh
this information is easily accessible on
on the web
i suggest you go to
thermofisher.com
idx
and that will take you directly to our
oem teams page which has
a lot of information on these products
as well as
a nice tool called a flip book which
goes into depth on many of these
products so you can download this
flipbook and it would take you to all
the relevant web pages for these
products
thank you next question
how long can it take to manufacture and
ship an order and what can be done to
minimize the lead time
yeah so this is a tough question because
it can vary depending on the quantity
and and product that's being requested
so
the range of time lead time can be for
anywhere from
two weeks to
several months in terms of lead time
depending on what's being requested
so we have ways to help our customers
and partners
get product when they need it
so if it's something that's not
forecasted and needs to be made to order
we suggest you know working together
with your global oem partner
to
forecast
potential needs
so that we can stock things such as raw
materials and intermediates to minimize
these lead times
so that can take in something that might
be a several months lead time down to a
couple of weeks
we do also have inventory catalog
inventory that research use only
inventory that we can utilize
to help
bridge any gaps in terms of waiting for
our made to order
products you can potentially utilize
some of our inventory that's in our
warehouses
to
solve an urgent need
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
is there a team similar to the gold team
that works with customers for cell line
um there is it's actually part of the
goal team there is a
cell line licensing expert and and we
can send you their contact information
and they would be happy to support you
well thank you anthony do you have any
final comments for our audience
i just uh want to thank everyone for
joining today's seminar and please feel
free to reach out to me if anyone has
any questions on any of this content
well thank you again anthony for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye